here at home a rally in downtown las
vegas is happening in honor of those in
afghanistan madison kimbrough is live
tonight with details as that rally
continues madison
yeah this rally started at 5 p.m and as
you can see there are numerous amounts
of people out here just take a look as
you can see people in support showing
their support for those fighting for
afghanistan right now many of which have
family that are dealing with tragedy
overseas the goal of this rally is to
extend the evacuation past the deadline
of august 31st to allow more refugees to
come to the u.s as you can see things
are pretty calm right now i think
they're taking a little bit of a break
but this is expected to last for about
an hour to an hour and a half originally
the event was set to last for an hour
like i said but due to the great turnout
the organizers are peaceful peacefully
continuing excuse me for organizer
mustafa abdi he is proud to be an afghan
american and says to all of his people
fighting back home he wants to do all he
can do to help
breaks our heart you know i mean being
in this community seeing what's going on
back home
you feel a tremendous amount of guilt
we want to do something we're here
united with the afghans around the world
17 countries are protesting today to
extend the state and open the gates
so as you can see many people holding
handmade signs and flags proudly
displaying afghan colors metro is
currently overseeing things here as the
rally is taking place again originally
this was set to take place for about an
hour but because of the great turnout
this could last to 6 30 to 7 o'clock we
are going to keep it here and give you
all the latest information and details
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now